all right so uh it's the bootlegate
podcast we got Eastside Juan in the
building we got Sada baby in the
building we got Skillet baby in the
building
it's a Detroit situation in here and
decided right before we went live he was
like yo cab make sure all the fans know
when I do these clubs they got to come
up and touch my beard I like it a lot
definitely
no but you got you can't just touch it
you gotta rub your fingers you gotta
pull it
so how long
[Music]
get up quick
y'all get somebody beat the [__] up you
hate people touching your beard I don't
like people touching my face just your
face
I feel like wait a minute is that the
first thing women reach for though is
the beard
um
we'll be like like probably like one out
of five a dinner like off the dribble
trying to touch my baby you have to be
like yo I just grabbed a hand okay I
just grabbed their hand what if I just
grabbed your cheek right now would you
like that
[Laughter]
you ain't gonna say five is a lot of
women five one out of five yeah
I'm saying I'm saying like if we taking
pictures or something like I'm doing
meet and greet or like that's wild like
like one like probably one out of 85 but
damn they're just like oh my God you've
hit me and just try to touch my beard no
that's crazy nah it has been like a
couple instances to where it didn't just
super duper irritate might just be like
God down but
I
wanted to tell them that I always hate
on them yeah it is glorious it's good
man being a pretty fire but much better
you don't have a you got a better
mustache than me
Skillet baby
non-existent mustache well that's
different from Whitford when he used to
didn't it used to didn't beat her at all
hey you know I mean little baby girl
facial hair like my teenage son bro I
was your teenage I was your son 17.
so you saying my beer don't look better
than that
what is this this is stubble that's not
a beard that's that's more than stubborn
stubble is crazy a little goat it's a
goat tea okay so a goatee is not a beard
it's a little one has a beard a little
goat little goatee you don't get what
I'm doing Juan got the best mustache at
the table
cap
have you had anyone think you were
Muslim because of your beard
no no they caught it uh they call it as
a Dominica today
that's tight I mean shout out to the Dr
is a good place to visit everybody no I
want to be telling me we're supposed to
go they have this drink in the Dr called
Mama Juana with the wood in it with the
wood in it bro and now every every
Resort they're like they call it
Dominican Powers respect Viagra yeah
supposed to get you a horny just help me
at work have you had it I don't do
performance enhancers how have we
already discussed this before you're not
the honey pack guy not my nickname what
is your nickname perk you off the perk
huh
that's an enhancer I'm the perk oh you
are the perk
hmm
yeah I know you do yeah man and and
Rhino gas station pills and honey honey
packs I have that I've done honey back
but I don't do honey pigs dog right here
though
who who won right here one you do a
honey pack no he go to the field
Pharmacy hey have you ever had a
Bluetooth
that's on the YouTube commercials
somebody give me that that's actually
called the blue shoe no you anything I
got the drink oh yeah oh the Rhino drink
no you got blue juice yeah yeah it's a
uh listen if you go to bluetooth.com and
you and you use the promo code bootleg
right now you'll save oh you promote a
whole entire free month they give you a
month for free blueshoe.com what are we
talking about yeah my boy tap my boy
Tata Glover man ball is like boober here
Bluetooth uh sponsor too yeah well
listen have you guys ever had a generic
Viagra no like I never had viagra's yeah
they told me that that you start seeing
green and red oh viagras yes I'm scared
of that boy
I ain't scared of it I'm not scared
well the thing is is like if you're
drinking or you're on certain substances
right because it's been like that since
I was 16. you ain't get drunk and y'all
turn it up if you hear me you can uh you
know take care of the shortcomings I
should have never got I should have
never got a drink when I was 16 and if
you hit me ever since then I'm like well
it's gonna make it turned up like that
you feel me I tried honey pass before I
don't like them you know what I'm saying
but enough liquor you know me yeah you
tell my Bluetooth
I ain't got no Bluetooth I call
everything Bluetooth though because I
know what that is have you ever had sex
on mushrooms yes yeah
yeah what what's your guys's review it's
fun it's nice that's fun I don't really
like mushrooms though
I don't like them [__] but he had a
mushroom face yeah
one you had a fan no I just really this
is this my thing you know what I'm
saying I'd rather eat shrooms and do a
lot of other [__]
you know
crazy dog picture being sober around
everybody else's room mushrooms
mushrooms like them [__] were mad at
me at Molly and that was cool no I mean
it was just like on a relaxing tip like
focusing he looked like the man of get
out of here
you ever have a therapeutic experience
on mushrooms no no [__] I had you
didn't eat a bad trip I had a bad trip
in the house of mushrooms
I thought all right so the first time so
like right when it was getting real
popular you hear me so I had
[__] like I was taking them in
micro doses saying like yeah damn it was
having essentially the same effect like
I feel like a perky ad with me like on
the focus inside you see what I'm saying
yeah for sure have you focused and my
head I'm like all right I've been my
girl does I'm like I'm gonna take I'm
gonna take like more than a micro dose
I'm gonna take a little chunk of the bag
tops up there and I'm I'm gonna eat some
of the [__] yeah I [__] with them one
by one though but like I'm like I'm
gonna grab a bunch
oh what I thought was not a bunch but
maybe more than what the [__] I'm
supposed to have and I'm like I'm gonna
play the game you feel me yeah so I took
him like on some like an end [__] on the
game type [__] boy I'm gonna eat some
right now and I ate some I ate the
[__] look the little chunk I took and
I'm sitting there and I get through one
match we're playing uh Call of Duty then
I get through another match and I feel a
little bit just kick in but they had an
oil okay let me just kicking in [__] by
the time we got to the third match them
[__] was on me
I'll be right back I ain't come back for
like three hours [__] I took 17 showers
[__]
I I switched my pajamas three four times
and then I got all the sheets off the
bed [__] yeah [__] I was
standing in it so like for my bathroom
17 showers in three hours what did you
take to make you do that mushrooms
I used to think I could like me it was
real it was penis envy Evie
it wasn't no chocolate it was the actual
mushrooms bro I'm watching [__] I'm
watching Hellboy
from the shower because I can see my TV
for like if I can open the door I don't
watch it they're gonna be this enemies
hey you don't hey and they got a gay you
penis envy mushrooms you ate them yeah
you gave me mushrooms bro the name of
the strangest
penises to you this is drugs one for me
right yeah
[__] bro he was a superhero I'm
watching him pop perks and [__] he gonna
play basketball he got all the Energizer
button these type of [__] in him he just
don't give up right so me I don't do
drugs so I tried like damn I'm gonna be
cool today I tried to do the perk you
feel me yeah
in Kentucky when you did that a video
with King Vine and you couldn't find me
I was sleeping a car
why I feel like this am I dying and my
body was heating up from the inside out
and [__] and I'm excited to him you feel
me I can do that okay I see him do it
and then go put up like 18 points yeah
yeah so I thought I could do that but
then my heart stopped
[__] you never told me you popped no
purpose because I was scared for real
and I don't let y'all know when I was
scared
for my life for real [__] this was
where is this in Kentucky Kentucky yeah
I'm wondering where the [__] you was you
really was missing that's funny bro
whole time cause listen why I try to
kill it it may listen cause every time I
every time I be saying something about
oh like having that Dickie suit on that
night you'd be like I remember that
night but I don't remember you at the
video shoot you was in the [__] car
sleep because Ryan gave me some fentanyl
who gave you what Juan provided that I
was super Gremlin and [__]
oh that wasn't me man I don't know what
he's talking about he didn't drink water
and then I just just no he used to he
used to smoke like like the most the
most I seen him and if you want to call
it the dream face for skillet like he
smoked a lot of weed we smoked together
a lot you feel me but my baby used to
smoke and
like how I smoke
17 Blunts and then I might look like I'm
blowed at the end of the night [__] by
like the second blood it'd be like it
look like we don't smoke the pound like
dude he used to look so high because
listen he's like as [__] he don't even
pass his blunt no you used to look at
him he usually didn't pass his Bunch but
I'm not gonna you know he passed the
blunt too he had passed me his blood
it's 50 bucks you know you know you've
been to the house
it's 50 Blunts and everybody passing me
to blunt and I'm the one that don't
smoke for real of course I'm a little
like I died because you got 50 I'm 19.
yeah I never really smoked for real yeah
I mean you know how's it going we took
you to the block you know yeah you guys
have a pretty interesting uh crib going
on that's not kept so how many people
you think you passed the blunt tool no I
do when I started my statement up I
didn't say I was smoking a bunch of
[__] that's how I smoke with
you I said [__] you smoke a lot and I
used to smoke with you
we literally was like the only [__]
with that grade of weed around [__] for
a long time three times
they they get they put moon rock in the
blunt
how I'm supposed to survive oh yeah that
Moon Rock have you [__]
it's like that like the easiest way for
us to explain Guru rock is like it's a
form of Moon Moon Rock but it don't [__]
your blender it's super smooth and it's
always made with like top shelf flour so
it's the [__] a product that our cousin
made he got us he got a certain recipe
that nobody got no nobody got a lot
shout out to the floor you know what I'm
saying yeah like he got membership cards
all type of [__] like he's been in
Detroit for a long time yeah but we
didn't take it out of town and you know
it's still going you know what it is hey
yo so how did you guys meet you and Juan
this is my cousin oh you guys are
related so you guys
you don't think they both look like the
Mickey
it's
did you say both of them
yeah
Dominican
I see it one looks like he's a retired
baseball player Sammy Sosa right bro you
don't look like Sammy sorry
I knew it I can't I said this last night
I agree with that now I don't know
before he went light light skin
me no y'all think I like like you
already sent me something can we pull up
a picture or send me something please
see that's how God work I literally just
Googled that [__] the other day because
I was looking at the white pictures I'm
like damn this [__] look crazy
turn around man look put the camera so
this don't look like him let me see how
you looking so I can meet the face
no you're crazy
and you have that [__] glass on your
phone nobody could see it that's seven
so cool
can you see privacy screen can you see
no no I see it but I don't see it no man
that's you [__] crazy I don't look
like that [__] bro let him grow a beer
you have stipulations yeah I don't look
like him check it no that's my talented
family yeah
he played football he played basketball
they they the ones for real not he rap
get money he managed to get money they
just changing their life around doing
all that type of [__]
he cooked
he did some other [__] he's cooked
putting out records now I'm chilling
Juan how many records have you put out
just one
are you gonna you're not rapping on
these are you no I had no say so in the
record he got him he got the songs he
rapping he used to rap or you told me
you were wrong
yeah put a beat on he'll turn up he got
no no his first take always legendary
give us a beat real quick dude
[__] you man
this is a side of baby type beating
that's crazy yeah I'm gonna walk that
[__] cause let's get it [__] come on
come on man
y'all [__] ain't never sold man yeah
you mean [__] shut the [__] up
[__] y'all [__] ain't get no money
dumbass
they ain't tripping yeah that [__]
supposed to stay in the house come on
let's get it come on
come on you go shut the [__] up on one
a little bit [__] about to make big cuz
rap about to make big could snap
we on the map
macaroni cheese in the Trap do not get
your [__] ass smack yeah
when I come don't let yeah pull up on
this block with that Mac yeah
we shooting craps
got a skinny [__] on my lap no for real
where is it pull up on the fence because
I know they smoking crack yep come on
well I gotta rap yeah yeah
come on why you gotta
wrecked I'm a CEO I don't rap
you lied you said if he wrapped you
would rap
why because why I gotta rap you got it
all my life all I did was trap yeah try
to make it happen get them snaps yeah
now we getting Millions off the rap yeah
I used to take it down away yeah I ain't
got nothing else to [__] suck yeah
call me anything just don't call me gay
you know what I'm saying
shout out mace
why did mace what's up with the mace
shout out cause I [__] with it
man stop well he was [__] with him he a
gangster turn hey mace's show I'm saying
pause
now pause you for that I said that
because I got the show it's a great
hey it's a good show that's all I'm
saying damn that's all I'm saying
I uh First Take One hey y'all
kill the season you hear me that's what
I'm saying
so I gotta ask yeah
talk to him the first time when I saw
him and tee grizzley were working
together the first thing that came in my
mind was like [__] I've DJ'd at a
nightclub
that Sada was at and I was asked not to
play t Grizzly yep and I was like whoa
[__] because I knew you guys had like
you know you're falling out but everyone
I didn't know how you would feel about
them working together and it was so
amazing to see you guys together yeah
because I feel like man
what was that like for you to put that
behind you bro I feel good man
I feel real good just like
[__] was long overdue
um whatever I wanted to Harbor my
[__] anger about was some [__]
I felt like I had the right to be mad
about for a long time but in the same
token it was hindering the progress of
[__] around me and
she a Bros tagging some money but more
so than anything I'd be liking to feel
good you know what I'm saying and
looking at so much [__] and staring at
[__] that [__] don't be feeling good you
know what I'm saying like I want to get
back to feeling good like I quote
unquote been in the house for like two
years you know what I'm saying
before [__] was bad before she was
starting to get good like and the guy
still was just in the house you know
what I'm saying like I'm hanging my hat
on blaming it on missing my daddy but
like [__] got to get up and do
something you feel me so
I missed him and I feel like he missed
me too and little brother put it
together and [__] whatever the [__] was
an issue that [__] don't exist no more
you know what I'm saying we going
forward I love it it's a it's a big deal
a bigger man like
that's a big deal man we need to do that
more you know yeah at the end of the day
ain't nobody gonna kill each other do no
[__] like that we might as well just
like yeah I need some money keep them
moving and you know it's about the
energy and the vibrations you know and
it's good for the city to have two of
the OG's two of the guys
I feel like you and him really kicked
the door down for guys like skill uh for
guys like I mean you know although this
whole new Detroit
and so just I just think like there's
just to have the harm Harmony between
you guys is big for that for the city
yeah because we've seen Star Wars yeah
yeah they Mount Rushmore for Nine Mile
Everest I mean [__] like I swear to God
like I like I I appreciate any knowledge
that they give me but I'll really be
giving the [__] about I know how he feel
about me you feel me and then a few of
my [__] close to me feeling I
really be standing on that because
you get to looking for
how can I say it uh validations in areas
where a [__] think you don't care but
like to be honest [__] damn they care
about all this [__] you feel me right
you get to looking for them knives you
you really ain't gonna get them knives
all the time because [__] go
with fads and what's going on in the
knowledge looking at a lot of facts you
know what I'm saying like
and to keep myself being caught up in
the EP I mean like I I gotta try to not
pay attention to it and just
hold on to knowing that I got real love
coming from this [__] I got real love
coming from this [__] yeah then the
[__] I love for real so like
yeah if we if I did do some [__] for the
city you feel me I just was trying to
stay true to [__] knowing that
I'm from Detroit but as far as me
looking for a [__] to do that
if he say I'm up there then all right
I'm happy I'm doing my due diligence and
his ass yo crazy you didn't make the
freshman cover by the way it was one of
the wildest snubs of the Year
man I don't feel like it's a snub though
I thought it was I don't why not I don't
even I don't know I mean last year there
was two guys from Detroit right this
year I was like yo like I mean Detroit
to me just moving even faster bigger I
don't feel like I'll do it you got one
of the best albums of the Year enough I
ain't did enough
I don't know man I don't know bro
I want you to stay positive looking at
it at all times yeah maybe next year
like but as far as as far as like you
saying that that ain't like
you shut up bro cause I'd be saying I
don't feel like I did enough though like
like far as musically right like yeah
for my city I'm big in my city and stuff
like but like on the worldwide level
yeah I got a record now it's [__] on
there that made that [__] that's that's
not worldwide neither and like bro but
you not all right so hit me up if you
hear me you know I know it's cool I just
want to talk to him bro [__] you not
local you did a whole [__] lot
uh a [__] alive they say they don't see
your [__] more so than bro it's the
[__] on that [__] bro I never heard
they names before and I'm not just
saying that because I want to tell you
to see your face you feel me bro you did
a lot brother but you know what I'm
saying and and and and more so than just
saying you did a lot bro I don't know
what they stands is or what they hold
the burn from his friends like what you
doing but [__] you did enough if I had
to say something you know what I'm
saying to make the [__] bro I
understand you've done more than that
I'd be feeling like it's different
markets and music maybe maybe they know
some stuff that we don't know you feel
me as long as I sell records and I
Elevate and I get better with my craft
I'm satisfied but I don't feel like like
I just wowed the whole world to where I
just had to be on the fresh release you
know y'all saying that and y'all got
y'all got like your opinions matter to
me no
bro okay so I I hear you saying that but
[__]
right there
all 12 of them didn't wow the [__]
world bro
like [__] it's it's granted it's some
[__] on there [__] yes I've heard
they music but like [__] I've heard
your [__] non-biasedly I've heard your
[__] [__] more so than I've ever
heard a song from like three people on
them up yeah there's like a few people
and there's no knock to death but [__]
you feel me you know how I be feeling
about that situation so I hope it's like
[__] I
I know you but now wisely I still would
know you and still not have heard them
[__] like say I wouldn't meet you and
I'm just on Tick Tock or Instagram bro
[__] yo songs is everywhere yeah we
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our folks at my bookie
man look my bookie NFL season is
approaching and you know what they just
added that I love is that early cash out
let's say you got a ticket and it's
looking great you can cash out early on
that ticket all right I love it all
right plus of course my bookie's got the
full casino going down and if you sign
up right now using the promo code
bootleg they will give you that first
deposit bonus up to a thousand dollars
all right so head over to my bookie ASAP
um look we got a NFL coming there's
baseball you can gamble on right now and
of course the full service casino
blackjack with the real dealer uh
roulette craps whatever you're into slot
machines you could do it and cash out
right on my bookie all right all you got
to do is sign up with that new promo
code bootleg when you sign up trust me
when I say it's a new account they're
gonna get you that uh first deposit
bonus all right so go to uh my bookie
right now use that promo code bootleg
when you sign up for a new account also
got to give a big shout out to the
family at kingpong
um the official sponsor of the bootleg
cab podcast what I love about King Palm
is of course it's all about organic all
right no tobacco this is straight
organic um leaves it's the only thing I
smoke out of and what I love about it is
they have these terpene infused flavor
tips and they are so good the squeezing
pops this is the watermelon
um man they got the dragon fruit they
got the grape whatever you're into trust
me they got it all right they're
available at your local smoke shop
um you can also go to kingpom.com and
use the promo code bootleg and save half
off so 50 off if you use that promo code
bootleg kingpom.com and uh man trust me
the squeeze and pop is where it's at
I've had so many people come in here and
they're like yo you squeeze and then you
get the flavor right away all right it's
and of course it's tobacco-free it's a
healthy smoke so make sure you rock with
King Palm at your local 7-Eleven your
local liquor store or go get 50 off at
kingpong.com promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview
yeah gorgeous shit's going up gorgeous
right now but gorgeous weren't really
going nothing but like no right now
right now let's go I mean as I'm saying
you still was juicing though yeah you
was juicing but it's like I'm I'm
limited well back then I was limited to
a certain Market of people like and
gorgeous and they also probably put that
list together like
probably early it'd be pretty it'd be
preoccupied I heard that they a few
people I bought their way on this year
and they haven't done that before but I
mean yeah
it was a different type of group of
people on there like it was singers as
dancers right some rappers yeah like I
liked um like they like that rear they
had one thing what's the singer [__]
names
Friday Friday I like Friday on there
um
uh what's going on there a little
brother she deserved to be on there glow
uh rifle man
yeah Rob deserved it
I've seen people that's like more like
um EDM music that's what it's called
yeah
you feel me so I know like I understand
how big they are the music is in their
Lane you know no I'm not saying I never
I don't listen to that music so I don't
but we wouldn't know but they look like
they do EDM you get what I'm saying like
Okay it looked like they do EDM so what
the [__] would we know he said they look
like
just like let's say this baby try and
stream more than everybody in Detroit
okay so you don't play him in the clubs
right you feel me no but he's one of our
top rappers right but you would never
hear baby child in the club but he got
some of the biggest songs it'd be like
somebody just going to the club and only
determining what's hot from from just
the one place no it's just no it's he's
from Detroit but like what his crowd is
it's a crowded [__] that's not
in the industry right right right he'll
make ghetto Rapture he don't make that
type of music
one of the best leaders first time I
played trying in the hood for for cousin
them on Van Dyke [__] same area y'all
was in [__] [__] like what the [__]
is this food what you got on the damn TV
and I'm like bro this [__] ass [__]
sweet I'm trying to hear y'all [__]
gonna get it hey you know who's fired
that I just got hit to this year was
Cash kid ding you just got yourself just
got here bro
yeah
earlier this year I I kind of like and
he came up here and freestyle and I was
just like no he could he been cold he
just happened
ever come out the city he was one of the
first people out the city 20 million
views like that man yeah
all right so you're gonna put out an
album one
yeah like I'm putting together something
for the people what you calling it it's
eight count like you know who was
producing it with you yeah she me say
who executive you ain't got an executive
producer you're just gonna pick
everything yeah
The Soul Man give them something to feed
off of you know yeah from these guys and
a few other guys you know hey what what
you know it's crazy because I I didn't
know that uh you and boldie were related
as well because of Bojack because like
sonically you guys are so kind of
different yeah he rap He rapping a lot
of left Pockets like he's doing he's
specifically a left-handed rapper I
loved it I like that he was just yes out
of town on tour it's his birthday it's
his birthday he just is in Belize or
something it's his birthday happy
birthday because
he just had he just had an accident and
he'd bounce back from the accident
against like his neck a little stiff but
he back walking working like Bojack one
of the coldest [__]
putting it like the cadences and the
[__] he say and he a [__] like that for
sure say some [__] I had to listen to
what the [__] you said a couple times
and be like I don't know what that is so
I'm gonna google it you feel me he like
narrate the streets 227 drugs man he
narrate that [__] him and Alchemist got
that [__] chemistry great ass
chemistry God it's fire it's so good man
so good hey what is the status with uh
obviously miles Bridges was on your guys
is he still signed y'all don't nobody
leave this squad unless you just say I
ain't big Squad okay could you hear me
is he doing all right he's great he got
a contract uh we talked to him if not
daily weekly if I don't talk to him he
talked to him if he don't talk to him
brother talk to him like that's real
family yeah you know what I'm saying
like so he's doing shout out to him
being happy though that's all about to
say like we care about that [__] he's
happy he was going real trans babies man
you is crazy
like in a month in a minute for a minute
like he was in a slump like and he
wouldn't let nobody know but you could
tell all right I can imagine he's
irritated by his sister
he was going through it too he popping
out you gotta understand like you right
there from I could only imagine how I
feel to be right there [__] days away
from the biggest payday of your career
or your life insane and some [__]
happened like how it happened bro and
you just you know so like the prayers
was up for him at all times and we great
we glad he about it there bro that's
important he back playing basketball you
feel me like he been doing music or keep
doing music and because he's a [__]
good rapper he's yeah he's dope but he a
great basketball player for sure and I
feel like he just was getting in his in
his bag where people were like oh he
been in the gym every day and I think
feel like he gonna come back better
like he's about to have a great season a
career season like they need it and the
[__] that he was about to get they're
gonna have to pay him like y'all gonna
have to stuff all that other [__] in the
trunk it is what it is man he got
through it [__] Rehabilitation all that
type of [__] and he's gonna play great
like he already was playing great and
he's everything all his averages go up
every year like it's a thing I do with
him before the season and I did it down
there every season instead of like
obviously couldn't do it last year but I
see my long-ass text message about how
much [__] I want him to do [__] and he
suddenly responding every time like I
got them [__] screenshots you feel me
and he do it the [__] averages go up
every season and I think from his career
ass from that last season he about to he
about to do it again about to go up
again I remember one day he told me like
I think we've seen him DeMar DeRozan did
this [__] too he told us he was playing
a business like I'm about to go for 30.
and this is about half time I did it for
30. and he only had about 10. wow what
did Mary tell you like when he wouldn't
change his Kobe's
by the end of the third for sure yo I
felt for you and I really was rooting
for you
this last lottery
man that should hurt my feelings hey I
really ain't want to talk to the next
book because I know the lottery before
about this I think you and I had spoke
right before the lottery before when you
guys got Ivy but uh damn dude I still it
feels like it feels like y'all should
have had women Yana no we spoke we for
sure we're supposed to have K and wimby
but in the same token [__] it like I'm
I'm I'm cool with with us getting twin
and I feel like us getting twins gonna
turn into some [__] that I didn't that I
didn't even know or expect to come about
him so with him Ivy during I like beef
stew huh who's twin uh I start Thompson
oh okay okay yeah we got it we gotta
start right oh yeah one of the two twins
yeah yeah sorry amen yeah we got we got
a Tsar we still got Jalen during like I
feel like he gonna get better and Jalen
Darren just grew like two inches yeah
he got to show me something him and
Marvin better like bro Wiseman gonna be
that way yeah
undoubtedly without him being get hurt
he's a a basket rim protector I forgot
you guys also have the guys though here
run protector though oh you guys so you
think so this this one this I asked you
about ready about James Wiseman do you
think
it was simply touches
but that he left like no I'm talking
about no now why he left I'm saying like
is that why he didn't flourish out there
because he didn't get enough time to
hoop he was injured from himself I was
saying he was healthy when they traded
him though you gotta think how I'm gonna
play James Wiseman and I'm coming off a
championship season yeah it's insane why
would I change the lineup it's no room
there's no room for nobody to grow in
Golden State Jordan pool just was like a
flower rose growing from concrete like
and he grew and then they got yeah it's
like it's no room they don't even have
the the pay like that the salary did
he's stupid hey if say if James Wiseman
had a big season how is that going to
pay him you're right no that's I'll just
that's that's the only question I got
but I'm saying that's the only question
I have like pertaining to him coming
from that way because a [__]
that said she like his niece still trash
like [__] like that you feel me like
more so
Marvin Bagley got a whole lot to prove
to me then watch me because I get I get
wise men to leeway and say like [__]
all right you was hurt a lot you feel me
badly badly you have done had an
attitude in Sacramento like you you
literally wasn't playing because you had
attitude my dad was saying videos of you
in the actual NBA game [__] telling
your coach no I ain't getting in when he
trying to sub you in but it'd be a lot
of I feel like politics it's like a lot
when it comes to confidence and and
um motivation I don't think a lot of
people be motivated to hoop for us
hey man y'all got Monty now the most the
richest coach in the NBA
I feel like my own coach I feel like he
can motivate them he will build the
culture yeah he'll build a culture a lot
of times just like this we got we have
I'm gonna do we still got Army
yeah we got we had homie one day I mean
a play good the next day we come we
don't got help me well we're here look
we're just playing Harmony
well he's playing behind me right hey
that's my my man Josh she works with Jay
Crowder so he will know okay Tommy was
playing good right he played good one
game right right the next game we come
to I'm sitting on the floor he's like
yeah I'm not playing this game I don't
know what reason but he's not on the
lineup for the game he told me he wanted
it so it's just like right that's not
motivation to keep playing good if I I'm
playing goodness
that's some [__] like I know I know he
told me I will if you hear me Casey had
to come to the moon and he don't play
with no more so [__] said he told me
out his mouth [__] didn't really
want to play for Casey because he's a
military coach like he type of [__] had
the [__] making their beds up in the
hotel oh yeah like an old school coach
for sure and he probably was like one of
the only [__] who was Pro Killian in
case yeah yeah
he only had been playing straight
what opportunity this season is the most
is the the best
how can I put it in nice words this
season this last season the only time
that I wasn't just full-on ranting about
killing Hayes on Twitter he was straight
he was he played decent he played like a
solid he went from literally but like
but all I'm like but brother when I was
ranting about him like every day on
Twitter guys I'm gonna I'm gonna run off
and piss are you good when I was ranting
about that [__] every day on Twitter he
literally was the most inefficient [__]
in the league like it was a stat on it
yeah but it's a difference of playing in
Australia where I think he's from
implant and
um and with everybody that could jump
run shoot slam dunk on you block your
shot from the top of the backboard it's
different like no it is now tell me this
I know you wouldn't have did it and you
probably don't remember that Dragon
cause I badly remember but [__] who you
you would you think he would have got
drafted what draft did he come in
or call Anthony right we could have had
Cole Anthony I told y'all
I wouldn't have even got certain I'm not
gonna even say the name because I I [__]
with buddy but I would have took
[__] Jalen um sucks I told you
all that and then in the Kelly age draft
I would have took Jalen Subs
no no no sex was in that draft it was
Jalen Suggs he can't we got a little no
Sexes after no we got Killian Hayes the
next year after we got
um
Whatchamacallit no Killian Killian was
here before okay
thank you thank you but I think Cole
Anthony came in that same draft no he
got drafted no Cole Anthony got drafted
with Killians no no the same year as
Killian because
the year before we got the number one
draft pick all right so I'm gonna tell
you so the draft that Killian was in the
number one pick was was Ant-Man
so we could have had
OB topping
Halliburton wouldn't have been good I
would have got Halliburton but cold
Anthony nobody knows I'm just saying
instead of Killian Hayes call Anthony
Tyrese Maxie Kelly
yeah
I would have got Tyrese for sure
and that's why he was the best one in
that draft bro my thing
bro Maxie been nice since Texas in high
school like these be the [__] a [__]
like me and brother been paying
attention to for a while and know what
they about right I was a maxi fan bro
like staying at Kentucky bro what that's
what I'm trying to tell you like [__]
he was I DM that [__] when he still was
in high school bro like I've been like
I'd be reaching out to all these [__]
you're trying to tell like bro you cold
you wanna be nice yeah bro my mama bro
so like when I see him in the draft and
then we pick Kenya Hayes over all these
[__] that I've been watching since
high school did not know is gonna come
and do they Thug fizzle but this it's a
lot of stuff going to that [__] pay all
that [__] I don't know what our cap at
though I don't know how much we got I
think we got a lot of money coming into
next season yeah I don't feel like we
can't we ain't have enough to pay these
people bro
um talking about the pigs that we wanted
to pick like once they would have got
good what
I understand so you'd be looking at [__]
from science and I don't know I'm
looking for this time
to be like yeah a lot of guys want to
play in Detroit a lot of people say that
like that's not a lot of people say I
don't want to go there
and then who am I to pick somebody that
don't want to play
yo why would I pick you if you don't
want a beer I mean [__] that I hate that
[__] you're good enough a lot of people
say that like I absolutely you don't
know how many people said I absolutely
don't want to go to that's what happened
with Josh Jackson he told the Celtics he
wouldn't play for them so then he fell
to us and you know shout out to Josh
good guy but Jesus that didn't end well
for us yeah he ended up on the two man
no great guy he's my baby yeah no we
know Josh Jackson used to be he actually
pulled up to the club in Phoenix I was
DJing you were performing and Josh came
through that's my little brother man
when I we used to walk in the gym
Josh was like
LeBron James in Detroit bro Josh is so
good like if you watch him in College
Kansas come on you had to see him in
high school right for sure they shut
jams down like
uh so cider what's up with the music man
what you got coming bro you I'm I mean I
know you got some [__]
um
uh I'm gonna step on my goddamn
I'm still struggling back and forth
between
uh doing the album or some [__] like
that but right now just singles pushing
videos out are you still with Warner
earlier no I was with Asylum or silence
what I meant to say yeah yeah no no more
straight indie no uh BMG groundwork oh
okay let me see I mean [__] with my main
man's Mark man you feel me but just
putting out whatever they think is some
[__] that we need to put out but as far
as me musically I'm focusing on
[Music]
um
recording and and getting back to
like my always rapping through and
through instead of
doing a lot of extra [__] in between
bars and [__] like that
and just
I ain't like me and brother ain't
recorded as much as we used to record
because of schedules and [__] like that
and I went around for a minute so I'm
I'm like relishing in the moment of
being able to record Wham again and we
having a lot of fun doing that and yeah
I'm just trying to
redo me again like like get back
to
quote-unquote slicing everything when I
jump out of the microphone like just
ready to do it that way instead of
thinking about it and
you know overthinking about it yeah
psyching yourself out like you said
you've been really kind of like you you
I mean you obviously move around I feel
like you've been kind of
on some introvert [__] in the last
couple no I have I have that's me that's
that's that which is not a bad thing by
the way no it's it's not
um
may I need to need to think like I never
had no time to ever really sit down and
think or
uh I dealt with a lot of [__] but every
time I was dealing with [__] we already
was on the road and out of town like
so yeah cousin there somebody get killed
whooping and it'd be days where I'm
waking up coming out the hotel down to
the lobby and wine already down there
smoking
and I can I know from the look on his
face something happened yeah cause he
won't be looking me in my house like if
you're smoking and he'll just tell him
like yeah your cousin dad or some [__]
like that but we already in the mix on
the road so like this the you don't have
time to to mourn yeah like no not for
real no funerals none of that type of
[__] so like the [__] with my pops and
then most [__] happened after that with
people Dan and just serious situations
here
was in the house
you feel me it's in my head in the house
looking in the mirror and not liking
what I was seeing
mad at a lot of [__] wow hey we got
to stop the interview to tell you about
our folks at Odd Socks baby shout out to
Odd Socks man the most comfortable socks
in the world Listen they got all the
licenses if you love chips you know what
I'm saying they got the Funyuns they got
the goddamn Doritos
uh they got Godfather what's up about
Odd Socks is not only is it the most
comfortable sock in the world that you
could put on your feet they also just
introduce their draws that's right we
got Odd Socks Basics underwear right
here which are amazing so if you um
if you just like that clean cut you know
we got the black ones or
if you're a fan of
a little bit of the uh Reese's you know
what I'm saying
look go to oddsoxofficial.com right now
use that promo code bootleg and you'll
save 20 off at checkout the most
comfortable socks in the world they got
the basics these are a pair of the
basics these are oh they're just so
comfortable dude like trust me when I
say all right if you're into wrestling
if you're into Transformers Power
Rangers goddamn Pepsi Coke they got both
you know what I'm saying shout out to
Odd Socks oddsocksofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout also got a shout out to the
family at Blue chew that's right it's
hot as hell outside what does that have
to do with Bluetooth I haven't decided
yet but I do know if you're uh dealing
with erectile dysfunction or maybe your
thing ain't thinking like it should be
thanging you know what I'm saying get
that Bluetooth same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis yes all right but it's
getting straight to your door in a very
discreet package no doctor's
appointments no doctor's visits all
right it's all online bluetooth.com all
right and this was dope about Bluetooth
uh one uh it makes your dick work like
it's never worked before we're just
being honest imagine like Barry Bonds 71
home run season but the dick form that's
how you're gonna be feeling when you're
on these blue shoes all right trust me
when I say it's a chewable form they
just drop their mint chewables as well
um there's so much to go down with
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg and they'll send you your first
month for free yes you asking me this
Bluetooth work of course it does find
out for yourself for free bluetooth.com
promo code bootleg all right go get you
a month of Bluetooth for free
and thank me later your wife will be
thinking me your girl will be thinking
me your dick will be thinking me you
know what I mean all right let's get
back to the interview yeah because I
feel like there was definitely like a
point in time where
I feel like you were kind of like at
least if people didn't know you they
would look at you and be like yo you
seem like a unstable dude no for sure
you know what I mean because you were
like obviously drugs are great you know
but I feel like a certain point in time
every time you would see like an
Instagram of you going viral with like
this motherfucker's [__] up no like so
like the the SpongeBob video when I was
when I looked at her bro I was not that
[__] hot I'm just an [__] with
exaggerating [__] and like I posted
another video doing the same exact [__]
you feel me but of course a [__]
gonna run with what they want to write
you know but I wasn't up no lean and
none of that [__] man the [__] versus
that sweet I felt like it was
intoxicating to me have you been able to
stay off the lean yeah I got that [__]
on the leash if I wanted Simpson don't I
don't like I used to have to have it bro
like that's that's a different world
[__]
thousands of dollars a day if you hear
me and I'm pulling
two three houses and some [__] like this
[__] a lot of pole to pop out right
here and I'm pulling like a deuce or
three in there and yeah Seven and Seven
and Seven and Seven and Seven go to
sleep wake up by my sleep pull up sip
some up running out faster mode [__]
I'm flying to Town Wine got it in the
part of this conversation yeah and I
already probably just a drink cause I
know you need to juice like oh that [__]
because that's the one thing right when
you're flying it's like I gotta find
this [__] I mean if I'm if I got a show
here but because when you're addicted
you're addicted when you when you when
you when you all the way on that [__]
like I was [__] you would fly in with
it or [__] you gonna find it by the
time you land and that's a that's an
extra hassle a [__] needed to eliminate
from his life like always damn near
putting the hearts on some [__] because
I can't find no drugs because I can't
find my juice has it have you noticed
your just your everything in like in
terms of
your health improving obviously you're
playing a ton of basketball I mean I I
play basketball I believe so well that
ain't that that that that that don't
yeah but yes you feel me you feel you
feel better [__] attitude better
all that type of [__] you know and you
look great well I appreciate it you look
healthy man I appreciate it you look
good bro uh boss obviously shout out to
camera
I just say one for you like do you
notice like a difference dealing with
him when he's yeah like you know because
you you gotta kind of be the babysitter
low-key you gotta make sure everybody
you got to get pick the money up you got
to make sure the hotels are straight you
got to make sure right it's a team
effort though yeah you know
like at the end of the day like
hell yeah he way different from how he
was yeah instead of like you know it's a
work in progress as it should always be
it should always be that way no matter
where you are in life well this [__]
ain't giving up yeah once you start
giving up it becomes you know
you gotta just keep going you know
matter shake that [__] off take some
[__] on the chin
and also a lot of bosses take [__] on
the chin they got to yeah
it's still my time to be boss you know
what I'm saying these [__] boss
at the end of the day
and yeah I see a difference
I was gonna say Sarah what do you think
is
the biggest piece of advice you could
give Skillet because he's got his own
imprint now right and he's bringing in
an artist obviously
um September 30th birthday party
everyone's performing cheerful will be
there yes Tigers will be there Saturday
over there
yes too rare a little Tyler yeah
plus a bunch of strippers no that's the
after party
what would be the advice you would give
to skila in terms of just like you know
being being a leader of his own [__] now
because you've been a leader for so long
I feel like anything that I that I need
to tell him I hurry up and tell him so
like as far as advice wise God damn it I
already gave it to him it's already in
them yeah yeah but we we had the part to
where we feed off each other more than
anything you know what I'm saying so
I'll be sitting back watching him now
and learning [__] and watching how he go
about [__] because it's situations that
he walking into that I already walked
into that I handled poorly in my own
opinion so watching him do it better you
feel me like I said I'm at the point to
where I'm watching brother but whatever
I feel like I'll be needing to tell him
or if it's some [__] that I could teach
him he always he listen he is sit there
and pay attention to me for a second but
I don't do a lot of that because I
didn't got to I did it for a long time
like always giving him talks and all
that type of [__] I mean I don't really
got to do that at all about nothing like
when I talk to him now I'm I'm waiting
on his response to see how he feel about
it right instead of me just leaving him
with a statement you know what I'm
saying that's dope I was going to say
obviously there's already a gorgeous
remix but it'd be kind of crazy if there
was a third remix and you got on it no
they they that's that's
life got to work how life work like we
let the music do organic [__] you know
what I'm saying that'll eventually come
what's something to ours that'd be big
you know you know what I'm saying that's
that's brother and brother [__] and two
of my little brothers you feel me like
I'm just happy with the song every time
I go to tick tock or I'm scrolling my
[__] what's the name out here
you feel me you're so crazy that record
is [__] going nuts well is is past
that bro like it's sweet as hell like
when you get one of them songs like that
you know what I'm saying to where
everybody just had one of the ones yeah
it's cool it's cool like [__] but it's
way more sweetie when you see somebody
else do it that's been with you for a
while yeah being like that's cold you
know I already had to report with t but
like to watch him have like some [__]
like that am I like you already had like
type B style [__] like that but like
being gorgeous one and then you got the
city girls on it and city girls killed
that and the song Still Gonna Keep it's
gonna go bigger it's still gonna keep
going I ain't gonna lie I just
appreciate being able to be in that
space and be talk like have a record
because you try radio on your shit's on
no because I used to turn the radio on
and all I hear is brother so for now
like I'll be around this city and I hear
myself the same way I heard big bro it
just be like damn so we we was working
for something because he really liked
the first day I met him he sent me a
whole paragraph and told me like this
how it was going to be the sweater guy
whole paragraph you probably don't even
remember told me how I was gonna dress
all type of [__] really so you still
have it no that was in my other phone
that's [__] legendary long ass
paragraph though I swear to God he
I always tell people he know how to be
an artist though he know how he want
everything to look and how you want
everything like as far as Artistry and
[__] like that like I'm not really I'm
not really artist savvy like
he's Studio etiquette all that I'm not
really like this playing tonight
my engineers
who are not here right now
they engineered you during the pandemic
when you guys branded both the rooms at
my studio I mean this is early pandemic
bro they were [__] their pants the
entire time
because I think what's the big white boy
that's always with y'all uh that was huh
he's like bro this [__] my boy's like
bro everyone's in here no one's got
masks on
uh there's a giant guy behind me with a
[__] machine gun
and I was like dude I had [__] covet
I remember having to pull up because my
guys were gonna walk out they're like
they were so they were [__] covered
[__] right I remember just like
pulling up the backyard one this is not
going on here like you know what I ain't
gonna be the one to tell these guys
anything I walked out I said you guys
just finish the [__] yeah yeah that
was that was a uh you were in the front
room
yeah that's crazy that was a good time I
don't even know why I just mentioned
that because I'm I'm getting a super
contact time he said something about the
studio oh that's what it was the studio
etiquette and then in my head I think of
a giant white man with a machine gun
see I don't know about like like when it
comes to like the circumstances around
him but as far as how he acts you know
how you you're creating how you're on
top because you're on top of your
engineer last night he left the studio
at we left the studio at 9am
La time
wow and we went at 9 00 p.m 12 hours
straight
yeah how much you guys we would have
left it like we probably in the last
three days probably got 30 songs I just
listen I just said that earlier I'm like
collectively between me you and and
twinsky then
[__] you didn't do it on your own then
there's a few songs I didn't did on my
own like allegedly probably like 30
something Jesus and then we're going
back to 99 to hand it off and just
because I feel like I like even though
we live in there I left out the studio
on a bad note so I got a bone to pick
with myself when we go in there tonight
I gotta leave I know yeah yeah I like
that
um all right well when's your do we have
an idea when you're like official
[__] debut on the on the obviously
you got to join album but
your debut like since you signed the big
deal sure is it Geffen yeah
I'm working on music right now we're
working on a release date for um our
album and stuff but
um I'm just working right now for real
for real I got a bunch of good music
it's it's hard to pick because like the
biology so good that I keep making good
music for real
all right that's a good problem here
what about you when you're putting out
your [__]
um a couple of months maybe you've been
working on it yeah hell yeah I got it
some [__]
what would be advice you would give to
up up and coming managers one that
you've the [__] that you've had to go
through that you know
oh yeah
you gotta believe in them well no they
got to really believe in you
because everybody think it'd just be
like
they don't see all the [__] that the
managers do they don't see all they see
is the glamorous and all that [__] hell
yeah we argue he cussed me out I cuss
him out
the same over here you cussed me out I
cuss them out like but the end of the
day is working
like
[__] doing [__] that
you know yeah we the [__] they like
yeah you gonna be dead about 10 24 that
[__] like you know what I'm saying like
you just was so horrible well the way
you guys drive no one will ever catch
you yeah I mean yeah but you know we got
we're doing a gun buy back two like
which is dope like you know what I'm
saying yeah like I saw that you can pull
up
a little bio gun off the streets that's
another thing too like you know what I'm
saying I've seen a lot of [__] I've
seen a lot of [__] get they run
include myself you feel me I've seen a
lot of [__] get they run and come into
some money but like
I'm talking about [__] that's stronger
than man you feel me like
and that's a skillet and I ain't gonna
say no other names you feel me but as
far as him
I ain't seen a [__] get more [__] back
as soon as you got some money like ever
just like ever like ever like I probably
don't do it two I probably did two
charity things
like within the last
three or four years ago I can remember I
know I was on the fire and we did
something like maybe three this [__]
didn't did like yeah he just had it
a year and a half two weeks ago
literally like he probably did like 10
children events in the last charity
basketball game we went to Footlocker
and brought the kids 200 pair of shoes
like he just he wanted them and he's
different why is that so important for
you to make sure you're doing
I just remember uh growing up and I like
like I was in high school inside of got
like big and stuff
and like and we had big rappers in the
city like to us yeah and I just wish
they would have reached back to us like
I wish I could touch like that get that
get that would have gave me hope like
right I missed out of that night too he
gave me hope like I was working
struggling got put out the house all
type of [__] doing all type of [__] I
shouldn't do and being touched by
somebody I I it don't even got to be
money or nothing it's just knowing that
like I'm around some [__] that could
change my life while I'm around somebody
like it's like you you see someone on TV
or on Instagram but if you actually like
to use the word touch like you see them
and you they're really there like oh
[__] actually technology and let the
kids touch me just so they can know like
this a real person it's not somebody I
see on TV and right he's not from here
like I'm really familiar I care about
your I remember sitting in the seat the
same schools that y'all was at so it's
important for us to go back and reach
back and let them know that like I was
sitting in your same seat you can sit in
my same seat when you get old as me like
you know yeah like he's so [__]
selfless just like
it's like if if you guys are leaders you
guys gotta lead by example you know that
motivated I ain't gonna say names but it
motivated a lot of people to squash what
they had going on for them you know
better of the city and how it looked
they see how they look they see how tea
inside of look they see how viral they
went they see how because it I think the
world lack a lot of positivity and it'd
be a lot of soft ass [__] that
wouldn't hurt nobody want to see people
be violent in drama 100 sure and it'd be
like because it's good it's like the the
life we are not like as many
[__] that would was
of course the positive I weighed the
negative with that situation with me and
bro but as many [__] was happy
you know it's still [__] that
wish we would have still stay mad at
each other yeah just because of that
narrative you feel me you know what I'm
saying like that that that's that's the
narrative that's more enticing for some
people but it's so stupid yeah you know
what I'm saying like [__] that the
other [__] don't get way more hero did
like it's supposed to and it took more I
feel like it took more for y'all to let
[__] go to to escalate it like it take
like I could go do something to somebody
so quick but it'd be like it take
everything it takes some real [__]
forgive yeah everything yeah be real
yeah actually to be a man first and be
like you know what
even if you like that [__] way harder
and people like my circle to check me if
I'm wrong yeah I don't give a [__] it's
all right cause he gonna tell me if I'm
wrong
it's just way harder relationship go for
sure everybody know that and I just come
in Saturn and tea for doing that though
and everybody think it's because of me
no it's because of them like they really
wanted to do that they was talking for a
minute and the first 10 seconds of them
talking I seen them smiling so it wasn't
really that big of a deal
great
uh all right so new music on the way
from everybody obviously it's going
crazy low CD Babs if I'm if I'm gonna
just put that in there we just we going
forward we're releasing the songs that
we think that people will want to hear
have okay that's it there it is man I
appreciate y'all pulling up
take care of my big Squad read the most
yeah it's September 30 y'all pull up
Detroit
Nation like real like a real real real
event International Players [__]
Masonic Temple Masonic temples September
3rd is that where they do like yeah
masonry like it's like a Freemason
they do there's
freemasonic teams
we gonna be there September 30th if so
they're gonna be there t gonna be there
G herbo the kids
September
girls you never know
outside from 808 you might see the
murder rolls in that
[__]
we ain't gonna see you [__] we is not
gonna see you [__] bro okay
[__]
that was great
pickleball's lit right now
man make sure y'all pop up man we love
Detroit shout out to everybody doing
their thing you know my next interview I
don't care because you know like I'm a
frequent Claire flyer so yeah flyer so
yeah like my next interview I gotta do
one of the um the intermission
commercials yeah yeah just like that
yeah like that this this this
episode of bootleg Kev is sponsored by
Don Julio nejo liquor nope nope
we eat the most Odd Socks and
click the links bio and said Kev sent
you and skillet sent you you might get
something free respect
respect the tent we got to do like have
Odd Socks oh yeah
oh good looking there you go yeah man
are you out or are the socks odd Kim I
appreciate you too man you always
showing this love of course man I'm
saying gotta get you back out there I'll
be in Detroit soon I actually really
thoroughly enjoyed my time there is
September 30th oh yeah
Corner Store brunch no no we need to do
it no no no we do we do we do it we're
gonna make it work yeah we'll do a
Cornerstone wrench too yeah
he's putting on the bootleg cab socks
right now there it is
all right
boom hey what up man uh you just watched
another episode of the bootleg cat
podcast brought to you by hard Dean baby
shout out to the family at hard Dean
don't forget
make sure if you're in Las Vegas you get
into that taxi as soon as you land you
get into that Uber say take me to
hardine all right they're gonna take get
you taken care of the most craziest
Premium Selection of cannabis you'll
ever find Under One Roof it's a vibe in
there the bud tenders they gonna take
care of you man listen tell them I sent
you they're gonna get you right shout
out to the family at Harding in Las
Vegas the number one dispensary in the
world all right and we are so proud to
be partners with them so shout out to
hardeen go follow them online Harding
underscore Las Vegas and check out their
website hardinglasvegas.com get you some
swag you know you can't buy this but you
know yeah shout out to hardine